hey what's up folks i'm international
master christy kavitsky
here with the recap for the 2020 u.s
senior championship
uh so this is the third in the u.s
championship series taking place this
month
with the u.s girls junior and the u.s
junior already taking place
check out my recaps to those tournaments
on this channel if you haven't seen them
already
and yeah the us senior was next in line
with 10 players
a lot of former u.s champions i think
there was something like a total of
13 or 14 u.s championships won
between some of the participants and
yeah tournament just filled with legends
some really really interesting chess
of course there was a lot of mistakes a
lot of blunders you know given that it
was
both rapid and online a lot of these
players were saying that they're not
used to playing online and
led to all kinds of uh issues for them
but i thought there was actually a ton
of really interesting and high level uh
quality chess in the event especially
some really really good
end game technique that we'll see in
this video
the winner as you probably know is
grandmaster joel benjamin
who actually became the first player in
us chess history
to have won the u.s junior championship
way back when
the us championship i believe he's a
three-time winner
and now the u.s uh senior championship
so the trifecta
so let me show you guys some of the
highlights uh from this event uh the
first one comes from
round one here we have gregory kindanov
playing against uh patrick wolf who
actually
hasn't played chess tournaments in a
long time but
was able to play mainly because the
tournament was was online and
could be completed in three days and not
a huge time commitment
um but here kaidanov unleashed i thought
a really really nice idea starting with
the move uh knight to
f5 uh sacrificing the piece
um now the immediate point is that if
g takes f5 this is what happened in the
game white will take on g7 and come in
with the queen with queen to g5
check um had black taken on c3 uh first
then white can throw in
uh knight takes e7 check for example and
completely open up uh
black's king as well this would have
been really really dangerous for black
so black decided to take on f5 bishop
takes g7 king takes g7
queen g5 check king f8 queen h6 check
king g8 uh white repeats moves once uh
always repeat as they say
uh although we'll see some players got
in trouble doing that in some of these
games
uh kaidanov repeats again and here he
ends up continuing the attack and
sacrificing another piece
with knight takes d6 a really nice
idea after e takes d6 rook takes d6 his
rook joins the attack now he has ideas
like queen g5 check and bringing the
rook in
now objectively white doesn't have more
than a draw here if black
defends uh properly but it's very very
difficult to do when your king is under
attack so stockfish points out some ways
black could have held here like queenie
two check
rook f2 and queen e1 and yeah apparently
white doesn't have more than a draw here
black can create some
serious counter play with moves like
knight d3 next uh this was definitely a
tough one
to find and wolf ends up sacrificing the
queen giving up the queen on d6
in order to get this kind of position
with queen versus uh
rook in two pieces but the issue is that
kaidanov here just
gets a lot of pawns especially after
this move he takes f5
hitting the knight it makes it very very
difficult for black
i believe the losing mistake came in
this position when black ended up
playing
knight f8 the computer finds some way to
hold with like rook d5
queen f6 knight g7 g4 and
yeah it's a complete mess i think white
has really good practical chances here
though and uh yeah in the game after
knight f8 it was
already losing after queen e3 and queen
h6
white ended up picking up this pawn
activating the rook
and just using the king side pawns to
advance forward
um i'll just play through a few more
moves here
white took this one rookie to check king
f1
and uh kaidana's technique was really
really good he pushes f4 goes queen f3
and then uh at this point he just takes
on
e3 just gives up the queen for the rook
and knight
going into this end game where he has
four pawns uh versus the knight
just way too many pawns for black to
deal with and uh
in addition uh white's active king
really just kind of seals the deal and
this was uh basically a losing end game
for
for black now wolfe actually uh came
back a couple
rounds later this is his game against
grandmaster uh dimitri
uh gurvich who which i think wolfe
played really really
well in this position he's already built
up an impressive attack on the king side
um and with his rook hanging on a5
mind you a pretty important detail he
goes ahead and just plays
g4 which is kind of an obvious
attacking move but black it was very
important to see that after
uh takes takes uh queen takes a5
queen takes h3 check king to g1 black
plays this really important move bishop
to e5
because the immediate f3 looks quite
obvious but would be met with
knight f4 and things are not so clear
here but by starting with this quiet
move bishop e5
now white just has no defense he can try
d4 but then he's going to get hit with
f3
and black is just mating very very soon
so really strong move here bishop e5
just sealing off
uh white's pieces from being able to
defend
white tried f3 g3 and rook f2 as kind of
the only way to
stave off the attack and give up the
rook but now black wins back the rook
throws in very smart queen h4 check to
keep the king
from escaping and now after king h7 uh
white's king was just getting mated here
now amazingly white actually missed a
chance right at the end of this game uh
to save it i don't think it quite spoils
the win i feel like it was a really
really nice combination by black but
i do want to uh show it here after rick
takes g1 knight takes g1
here had black found this move queen to
g2 the game would have just been
over he's hitting the knight white has
no good way of defending the knight
and if the knight moves then black is
just taking the pawn on f3
and position collapses but in the game
black played this move queen h1
and after queen b6 c5
white resigned because on king f1 bishop
d4
black is just winning the piece and it's
game over
but in fact had white played king f1 in
this position
uh apparently black is no longer winning
here might not even be
better as the move bishop d4 this would
run into queen f5 check or even
queen g5 where white is actually holding
and the knight is kind of uh
defending everything here um well
basically white is getting enough
counter play
with the uh the queen on on the fifth
rank um
so that was actually kind of an
unfortunate miss uh grievage could have
found this and possibly held the game um
but
as it happened queen b6 was played of
course the players weren't
probably super heavy time trouble c5 and
and that was that the next highlight i
want to show before we talk about
uh benjamin's performance uh comes from
one of the later games between shabala
and uh golden this is a pretty tight
game
very much back and forth uh and here
black makes
kind of a surprising blunder with the
move knight to b4
this might be a good tactics exercise if
you guys want to pause your video
and try to figure out how white should
refute this move
but at first glance it looks like a very
strong move opening up the bishop
against white's queen
uh potentially looking at the d3 square
for the knight it's queen also has to uh
keep in touch with the nine on f5 my
guess is black maybe expected something
like queen to g3 here
where he could play queen takes f5 a
takes b4
and something like c takes b4 where
basically the position is
close to equal both sides are kind of
okay here um
but instead shabala finds the really
really strong
retort h4 such a powerful counter attack
now the first point here is that if
black takes the queen on f3 y will of
course take the queen on g5
and in the resulting position not only
is the bishop and the knight hanging
but white also now has the threat of
knight e7 check in the position so
black is just losing material here uh
any any way they
they play uh for instance knight d3 y
can already just take the bishop
and then on knight c1 we can take back
on knight takes b2 we can go 97
check and we pick up the rook and
white will have at least an extra
exchange in the final position
might even be able to trap the knight at
the end of the line
and win even more material so
that was kind of the first point of h4
but the second point is that
if black tries to move the queen away
there's actually a problem with every
single move
for instance queen g6 this one runs into
97 check and black loses the queen
with check so no time to even take on f3
and if black plays a move like queen to
d8 well
white's queen is still under attack but
white can get out of the way
with tempo by playing queen g3 or queen
g4
uh threatening checkmate black has to
defend against this one and then white
can
uh take the knight next move among other
things on g6 i'm sure
knight h6 check and e6 are both very
very strong moves
as well uh so yeah really nice shot h4
that basically just won the game on the
spot for white i
found this really surprising and very
cool move the game finished queen d2
queen to g3
and for the same reasons as before black
is just losing
material here would have to play move
like g6 if you wanted to
defend against mates and now since the
bishop on b2 is hanging white can play
something like bishop c3 here
uh hit the queen and then think about
taking here next or going knight e7
check or knight h6 check or e6 again a
million moves and
white is kind of winning all over the
place but yeah really nice uh
tactical display there by by shabbat so
let's talk about
joel benjamin's games i felt like joel
played
a really strong and technical style
for most of the event he won a lot of
end games
converted a lot of slightly better
positions and in the
post tournament interview he felt like
he got a little bit
lucky in some of his games that
certainly happened but from what i saw i
think his technique was just really
really good
and he basically made fewer mistakes
than everyone
else um his first one that i thought was
quite impressive was this game against
uh
patrick wolf in this position black was
a little bit worse here and offered a
queen trade with
uh queen to c6 objectively i think this
was a reasonable decision
uh as black is supposedly drawing the
the end game but as joel kind of shows
here
he does have a pretty superior knight
versus bishop endgame as his knight just
has this beautiful square on c4
he can support the knight with b3 the
knight is basically untouchable and
white can put all of his pawns on light
squares
to play against black's dark squared
bishop
now objectively i think black could have
held this one but
it was not easy and especially in a
rapid time control
it's often much uh more convenient to
play with the knight because you can
bounce around the knight is very tricky
it's very easy to blunder a night fork
and
it's pretty simple to to play against
the the bishop you just
don't let the bishop attack anything so
once again black did have chances to to
hold here but white just continues to
make progress
actually an interesting uh detail here
was that already white could have played
the move
b5 uh trading his uh b pawn for black c
pawn but getting his king very very
active to
to a6 and as well as preparing to bring
the knight either to c6 or c4
i think this one would have been really
really close to a win for white
instead uh benjamin goes with for king
b3 a little bit slower king a4
and uh wolf ends up making a critical
mistake here
after a4 uh bishop f2
and b5 apparently stockfish can can
still hold this one
after takes takes uh and g5
and there's i guess the main point is
that when
white plays knight a5 and goes for the a
pawn with knight to c6
this is exactly the moment where black
needs to basically ditch the queen side
and start running uh towards the king
side
so something like king c5 knight takes
a7 king c4
with the very deep point that if white
pushes forward
black in this position would be ready to
sacrifice the bishop
and start running towards white's king
side i analyze this position a little
bit i
think it's a draw with with best play
i'm not even sure
i i think it's still black who has to be
precise here to actually uh make a draw
but
it's not too hard when your king is just
uh running towards your opponent's pawns
anyway this is you know what i would
consider kind of like a miracle defense
um usually what happens is players make
mistakes and
end up going down here black played
bishop d4
that a5 and already white is winning
this one
black tries to hold on to the a pawn but
after knight c6 jack and king to a8
benjamin found a really nice way to
break through and win the game here
once again if you guys want to treat
this as an exercise feel free to pause
the video and think about it for a
couple minutes
and uh well here white played the really
nice shot knight takes a
seven i thought this was a very very uh
nice and efficient way of winning the
end game the point is after bishop takes
a7
b6 uh the bishop cannot move back to b8
because white has b7
checkmate a really really cute mate on
the board
and otherwise black is losing the peace
so if bishop takes b6 king takes b6
in the resulting king and pawn end game
white's king is just obviously
much stronger and is going to win on the
king side
and perhaps more importantly after a
move like f5
which happened in the game b takes a7 it
feels like black might have some chances
because of the possible
stalemate but there's too many pawns
left on the king side
and black is just not in time so
black decided to resign here because
after any move
they try like f4 for example white will
simply release black's king
from the stalemate can even do it next
move can play king b6
g5 and king c5 like this and
uh once black's king is released from
the stalemate of course we just get that
same king and pawn end game from before
and white is just cruising to to victory
here um or in case of f-e-f-e-g-5
once again white even has a tempo to
spare but can already play king b5 here
and uh just go after the king side
and yeah black has no chance of of
saving this one
um so i i felt like this was a a really
nice
game it wasn't like perfect technique
because white wasn't exactly
winning from the outset but he posed
problems and made it really difficult
for
for black to hold and eventually
capitalized on on his opponent's uh
mistakes now joel i would say
got pretty lucky in his game against uh
your malinsky
uh he was actually just getting he got
totally outplayed out of the opening and
he was much worse with white
right out of the gate um but he fought
on and he
managed to get into an end game where he
was worse
with the knight versus bishop oddly
enough these two games were back to back
so he had
two back-to-back wins with the knight
versus the bishop and uh yeah i
basically made it hard for for irmo who
wasn't able to find
uh the best way of capitalizing on his
advantage
we got to this point in the end game
where black ends up making this
very very double-edged move e3 and this
actually ends up costing
irmo the game um it
felt actually like a really interesting
move the point is is that now of course
white is gonna have to
deal with the pond the immediate king d3
is of course a blunder after bishop
takes d4
and white would be unable to catch up to
the pawn
so instead benjamin goes knight f3 black
plays e2
threatening bishop f2 winning the knight
so white is forced to play
king to d3 and essentially this is a
pawn sacrifices now black plays king to
d5
with the idea that if white takes on e2
black would play king c4
and go after white's queen side so a
very very ambitious uh
idea for example white could take on h4
here uh
and possibly even take on g6 not sure
exactly what uh
black would have in mind here maybe he
can even throw in g5 g4
or maybe you can just think about uh
playing this end game out where the
bishop is
for sure going to be stronger than
white's knight
but ultimately the idea just doesn't
hold and
uh doesn't hold up and benjamin was able
to kind of
refute it with with good technique now
king takes e2 for the record was winning
after king c4
um white would have to find the really
precise
check knight e5 the point here is that
black can't take on b4
in view of knight c6 check we end up
getting a similar end game
to to this in the actual game and it
turns out to be
to be winning for white um just for
instance after a5 here for example white
can already play knight c6
take the pawn on a5 and again run to the
the king side we see this theme again
with uh benjamin here using the more
active king in the
king and pawn in game um and since black
can't take this pawn on b4 black would
have to play something like king to b3
and then white can play knight c6 uh for
example and then either a5 or b5
uh stockfish says white is winning here
i'm sure it would be a
difficult end game to play in in time
trouble um but benjamin's way is
actually
perhaps uh even cleaner he decides to
push
b5 here which i thought was really
interesting
now if black trades the pawn on b5 black
can certainly pick this one
off but white will take on e2 black will
take on b5
and of course in the resulting end game
white is not only snagging this pawn
but is easily going to be able to win
this pawn as well um
and uh yeah basically with the more
active king and extra pawns on on the
king side
probably should be winning for white he
can also consider a move like 95 and
then bringing the king in this way
just to make sure that he wins both
pawns and leaves himself with connected
passers
at the end so black can't couldn't
really go for this this would basically
be like white having an outside pass
pawn and winning
uh instead yurmo plays e5 leaving white
with a protected passer but
with the intent of going after the a
pawn here but it simply uh
doesn't work out after 95 check king to
b3
and very precise move here by white 97
really really strong uh threatening b6
and just winning black's bishop
black had to take on a4 b6 white ends up
winning the piece
and this was not the easiest end game to
to play for sure but it did end up
winning
uh for white with precise play
after king c4 uh white repeated here now
this was actually a mistake according to
the engines
i think stockfish was saying king c5 97
checked
king d6 and and black is actually making
a draw by some miracle
uh that was a tough one to to see i
think
most players especially you know the
guys that were trained
uh in classic soviet style you know
they're always taught to repeat moves
this might have been a moment where
repeating moves was was not good
um anyway yurmo does go back king b5
white plays knight d5 king c4
and now benjamin finds the the only
winning move in the position
uh knight to f4 getting ready to snag
the g6 pawn and then come back in time
to deal with
black's a-pawn so black played king to
c3 here had he just started pushing the
pawn
white would then uses king to stop the
pawn
and the point here is that white king is
going to be blocking the pawn and the
knight is just easily
picking up black's king side so if um
white is able to stop the pawn basically
it's game over black won't be able to do
anything about it and
we'll lose the game uh so yermo tried
king to c3 in order to keep white's king
shouldered off but king d1 king b2
white has time now to take on g6 and the
knight gets back
literally just in time as now in case of
a3
y would have knight c4 check followed by
taking the pawn
and again running the king to the king
side
so because of this check black had to go
king to b3
but now white is able to bring his king
in and stop black sapon
and with white's knight getting ready to
just nag the h4 pawn the game is just
completely lost and
uh black resigned so a bit of a lucky
win but still benjamin had to find some
really really precise moves in this end
game
uh to actually find the uh the full
point
now going into the last two rounds uh
benjamin was
a half a point ahead uh of his nearest
rival grand master eager novakov who is
having a pretty
solid event uh and actually your
malinsky does benjamin
another big favor here gives them
another gift
by defeating novokov and i think
inflicting
the only loss that novakov had in the
event if i remember
correctly so yarmouth kind of ends up
playing spoiler here he wins this game
while benjamin draws this gives benjamin
a full point lead going into the final
round
uh and then benjamin just needed a draw
in the last round although he ended up
winning his game to
to clinch uh the title uh but urmo
actually showed a
really fantastic technique himself here
playing against the
the iqp really want to show this game
just because it's very very instructive
he starts with the move rook fc one
indicating uh that he wants to trade
rooks
black decides to do it for him rook
takes c1 rick to c8
he trades on c8 bishop takes c8 and
queen c3
immediately grabbing the only open file
uh with the queen
black plays bishop d7 and now he just
starts improving his position
a5 b4 uh black is improving as well
bringing in the king now that it's
relatively safe
and here comes more improvements knight
b3 so the knight is heading to
c5 and the queen gets to use the d4
square
here black plays bishop e6 i think the
engines were uh pointing out this is a
mistake
saying that the bishop was probably a
better uh
defender on c6 uh but in in case bishop
e6 knight c5 is played
queen d4 king f8 and and now
white starts bringing in the king i want
to mention another move
that is possible in these types of
positions is g4
just trying to start advancing with h4
g5 and taking more space this can also
be
quite strong but yermo just starts
bringing in the king
king to e1 and black decides to
finally try to trade off this knight on
c5 without having anything else to do
it's certainly understandable
but white is unfazed king d2 and not
only does he allow a trait of knights he
actually
uh forces a queen trade going into
uh bishops of same color in game where
only white can really be better here as
this d5 pawn is just going to be a
chronic weakness for the rest of the
game
now i think black definitely could have
defended a little bit better here but
overall it's a very tough end game and i
believe it's basically lost for black
with
best play king b4 is played here setting
up bishop a4 check to
push black's king back so king c7 bishop
a4
bishop to d7 now this is a pretty clever
move by black if white
trades bishops here after king takes c7
uh white is not winning this king and
pawn end game like he could try king c3
king
c6 and king to d4 uh but i think black
is holding this one with a move like
h5 and essentially white doesn't have
enough tempos
to run black out of moves not to mention
black always has this move king to b5 if
they need
and can go after the a5 pawn so i think
objectively this one
is uh probably a draw so yermo keeps the
bishops
on the board king to c6 plays f4
now black plays g5 and uh very very
instructive moment here
in uh meeting this move g5 white takes
on g5
hg and now goes back bishop a4 check
because now the situation
has changed king to c7 takes on d7
king takes king c3 and the point here is
that after king to c6 king to d4
now with these moves included fg5 hg5
white has the potential to make an
outside pass pawn and
this is just the strongest potential
pass pawn in the position
and and black is just that lost you can
try king b5 but he's way behind
g3 takes h4 let's say take
take king to b4 white starts pushing
and white is gonna be promoting
the first and this one okay white
basically wins by
one tempo but one tempo is one
too many and that's it uh so in
in view of this black uh basically
resigned of course white can maybe even
play other moves here like king c3 to
slow down black
uh and then just promote his pawn in
fact that might be a
much simpler way of winning the game
here for white
as black's king is not going to be able
to to stop the pawn
but in any case really really fantastic
technique
had black not played this move g5 it
still would have been
a very very difficult end game at some
point the king would have to go back to
c7
y would bring his king to d4 put the
bishop either on
f3 or on b3 and ultimately it would be
very very difficult for black to to hold
this one this was just
a very unpleasant endgame right right
from the start so jeremy linski
wins that one which means that benjamin
in the final round
just needed a draw against the 10th seed
feeder master shelby gets here
shout out to shelby who i think really
turned some heads in this tournament i
mean he was
i think the only player in the field
who's not a grand master you know he's
the 10th seed
at least like a hundred points uh lower
than everyone else
uh he qualified by virtue of winning the
us senior open so he earned
his spot by qualification um but he
really brought it you know he was trying
to win
every game uh he played 1a3 in all of
his games as white he played the
chagoran and all these
uh weird wacky openings as black and he
you know he scored some points he won
some games so
you know i think he had uh a performance
to to be proud of
um but in this game okay he gets
outplayed by uh joel benjamin who
already actually missed a chance to win
in in this position uh with the move
bishop takes b2 check
this would have been a winning tactic
for black in view of king takes b2
and then either rook to d8 uh skewering
white's queen and rook and just winning
the exchange and winning the game
um benjamin misses this this one plays
bishop to g7 but is still
just much much better in the position
with better development and
white's pieces still on on the back rank
here um
he actually uh offers a draw at some
point uh
in this game uh to his opponent just to
clinch
first place i think it was a pretty
generous draw offer
as black is is much better but to to
shelby's credit he denies it you know
who wants to play for a win i think he
just didn't want his tournament to end
so he just wanted to
to keep fighting until the very end uh
which i i definitely
respect um but after uh denying the draw
for of course black uh
is in full control here plays this nice
move queen to d5
uh white goes e4 and then the queen
comes in with queen to a2
and uh yeah now white's king is in
huge uh trouble here bishop d3 was
played
c4 queen b1 black keeps the queen
uh drops back queen b6 queen a2 and here
comes the the winning tactic uh in the
game
pause your video if you want to try and
spot it bishop takes
c3 uh really really nice shot the point
is b takes c3 would be met with queen e3
check
and white would have to play either king
b1 or king b2
rook b6 check and either white gives
back the piece immediately and ends up
completely lost anyway or he goes king
a1 and gets mated after queen takes
c3 so this was basically over
uh after bishop takes e3 white boy tried
rook to d1 but
queen e3 check king b1 black's
initiative here is just
way too strong the king on a2 is
actually hampering white's king by
locking the king in and after takes
takes queen d3 check
uh white is just getting checkmated here
but by force if
king c1 there's bishop d2 made on the
board or queen d2 queen takes d1 was
also good
uh and after bishop c2 queen f1 bishop
d1
queen takes d1 uh that was the end of
the game good sportsmanship there to
play it out
until checkmate and uh letting joe
benjamin
you know win the u.s senior championship
and completing the trifecta
on a really really nice note always nice
to put checkmate
on the board let this serve as a public
announcement for you guys if you're
playing an important game
and your opponent has one you know nice
game and they have some kind of mating
combination
just let them play maine on the board
it's so much better everyone likes
playing mate on the board you know and
you would appreciate if your opponents
did it for you so i think we should just
make that
a new sportsmanship custom let your
opponents
checkmate you when they have a forced
mating combination on the board it just
everyone wins
everyone wins so yeah guys that wraps it
up for this recap hopefully you enjoyed
it if you want to see
any of these games there will be a link
to the lychee study that i'm using in
the description below
and up next is going to be the 2020 us
women's championship
which starts uh tomorrow with
uh regular coverage on uschestchamps.com
and i'll be back for another recap uh
for that event it's gonna be
really exciting so until then have a
good one take care